I don't see any logic to their plan
other than it's fire right we can
control combustion for a purpose like
driving a car you know we use the make
the car go forward very very simple but
uh if you don't have a control mechanism
for that that's the process I like that
but if you don't if you don't have these
control mechanism then it's just burning
everything down right so there is this
energy from the left and it is just
chaotically destroying consuming and
burning with no Rhyme or Reason
yeah I think it is doing that
um
you don't think that they have a I think
that they're looking for specific
outcomes and they don't understand that
the outcomes they're looking for are
going to be really destructive they keep
maybe maybe the young dumb dumb ones the
new executive order that Biden just put
out looking for uh to advance Equity
yeah Equitable outcomes I think the real
purpose is just to burn the machine to
the ground to destroy it all and then
afterwards who knows what you're going
to get Chinese communism